this autonomous car showcased at the
2013 gone Jiao Auto Show has a built in
fish tank and Javier direct created an
interface called puzzle facade that
turns an entire building into a giant
interactive Rubik's Cube Vsauce Kevin
here this is my world researchers have
discovered that male koalas have a
specialized sound producing organ never
before seen in land dwelling animals and
it makes the pitch of their mating call
20 times lower than it should be
relative to their size so yeah swing
over the edge of the world at La Casa
del arbol in Ecuador the swing set
allows people to feel like they're
flying off into an abyss at 20 660
meters above sea level it's connected to
a seismic monitoring station that
observes an active volcano nearby and
there's no harness or net or any safety
precaution whatsoever so riders use it
at their own risk
the zeizel is an off-road wheelchair the
year-round all-terrain vehicle is
barrier-free and electric and has the
ability to perform on snow sand mud
grass and stone the battery lasts for
several hours and it tops out at 35 km/h
ninja sphere connects all of your
devices in the home and is able to
monitor temperature lighting energy use
whether or not your valuables are moving
and even your pets presence the project
is open source so that anyone can
contribute with the hope that it will
help the ninja sphere cover a wider
array of devices in the future new wave
energy UK is looking to create a
high-altitude aerial power plant
positioned at 50,000 feet unmanned
aerial drones will harness multiple
forms of renewable energy where wind
patterns are more reliable and solar
energy is strong
longer there's also a smaller
probability of weather interference so
unlike green energy used today such as
windmills and solar panels there won't
be downtime we're fossil fuels are
relied upon as a backup this is a tiny
dwarf seahorse caching a copepod at
lightning speed because their heads are
perfectly shaped to sneak up on prey the
gyro seat on okawa lab is working on a
mirror that can change people's
emotional states by reflecting a
different image of themselves back to
the user by taking a picture of the
users face and subtly changing the
expression to look happier or sadder
they found that they can change the
emotional state of the person looking
into the mirror and they hope to
potentially use this in changing rooms
or department stores to alter your mood
while shopping or to help people
struggling with depression the last
camera capable of capturing a single
pulse of light cost half a million
dollars to create and students at MIT
recently created one for just five
hundred dollars using the new
time-of-flight camera you can see light
sweeping over the objects and eventually
lighting up the back wall they hope that
in the future this nano photographic
technology can be used for medical
imaging interactive gaming and car
safety sno2 is a hut for skiers and
snowboarders and comes equipped with
Bluetooth and GPS so you can calculate
your speed keep track of friends on the
mountain find your way around see the
forecast and view calls and text
messages all in real time
finally void from tundra is an
audio-visual installation that attempts
to visualize the idea of emptiness
I'm gonna leave you with a comparison of
gravity between Earth and Mars using a
rover and a banana oh and also Kevin I'm
going to leave them with something an
illusion it's called anomalous motion
the image is actually a still image but
your mind thinks it's moving I talked
about why in my newest video over on
Vsauce but Kevin yeah seventy five
episodes of mine below now yeah have you
guys watched them all if you haven't you
probably should yeah there's a playlist
at the top of this video's description
clay that check it out what well as
always thanks for watching